[MUSIC PLAYING]
Incremental Auth is a feature of
Google+ sign-in that allows you
to ask users for
permissions, as you need to.
Users who are new
to your app may
hesitate when being asked to
grant multiple permissions up
front.
However, if they see these
requests, when it makes sense,
they can better understand
how their data will be used.
Asking for consent
in context may reduce
friction, lead to more completed
sign-ins, and a more engaged
audience.
Take a look at 8tracks.
When I first signed in, I was
asked for only the permissions
they need to get me started.
Now that I've found out that
they can recommend music
based on my favorite YouTube
channels, when they ask me
for permission to access
YouTube, it makes sense.
Before I know it, I'm listening
to music recommended to me
by 8tracks, and it
couldn't be easier.
Check out our
developer docs to learn
how simple it is add
Incremental Auths to your apps.